oui
tu es les magouilles les chéris france
info a dévoilé aujourd'hui une enquête
au sujet de la france a un incroyable
talent l'émission diffusée sur m6 lors
de la saison 12 diffusé en novembre et
décembre derniers c'est l'oral aux incas
gagner qui remporte le concours
son humour son humour noir a su séduire
à la fois le jury et les téléspectateurs
souvenez vous j'avais écrit une chanson
en hommage à mon papa qui est décédé
mais j'ai finalement il est pas mort
alors bao tu va beaucoup mieux
on est vraiment content pour toi tu est
la preuve que sous nos yeux
de vrais miracles arrivent parfois
j nos téléspectateurs ont désigné comme
grand vainqueur de cette douzième saison
lors allen
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est elle qui a gagné incroyable
talent les voir on me dit que laëtitia
c'est fou ce qu'elle a dit dans le point
nous verrions on aura tout dans un
instant il existerait donc un lien la
révélation france info il existerait un
lien entre laura losne et les qu'antoine
l'un des membres du jury qu'on adore il
aurait déjà travaillé avec laure alone
avant son passage dans la france a un
incroyable talent il connaîtrait aussi
très bien son producteur jeremy ferrari
ça c'est normal en avril 2015 sur
comédie plus dans l'émission les jo
impossible de jérémy ferrari
on avait pu voir eric antoine annonce
qu'un sketch entre gemmani ferrari et
laura l'aude
donc ça fait un scandale lors alone
avait déclaré dans une interview à ma
chaîne étudiante diffusé en mars 2010
est qu'elle écrivait un peu pour eric
antoine et dans la france a un
incroyable talent eric antoine semblait
déjà séduit par la candidate
il riait même beaucoup à ses blagues il
a qualifiée de géniale alors on a des
images à vous montrez vous allez voir il
appréciait beaucoup
laura l'aude alors je vous le dis le
truc c'est que ils disent que donc eric
antoine la connaissais déjà et pour eux
c'est une tricherie alors que vous en
pensez regardez même s'il existe et ça
fait tellement du bien quoi ainsi ses
marques j'aimerais tellement bon ça fait
depuis le début de la saison que je dit
j'aimerais que qu'animaux risque une
humoriste gagne cette saison c'est ce
serait magnifique et c'est très rare
dans incroyable talent tu es jusque là
tu nous surprend à chaque fois c'est
extraordinaire
bon boulot super alors qu'ils trouvent
qu'il ya tricherie qui trouve qu'il n'y
a pas tricherie qui trouve sa tricherie
réservé ce qu'ils trouvent évidemment me
suis évidemment alors est vrai alors
écouter ses ébats genevois jean lacasse
tally de froid n'est pas tard j'ai mené
une enquête à la mode personnes alors
qu'ils ont d'abord un le choix est
assumé et cette personne était connu
avant de faire l'émission
le producteur a dit voilà je veux je
veux qu'elle vienne dont dans l'émission
donc là c'est la première chose ensuite
oui vous devez toujours vous l'année non
en fait vous allez vous regarder la télé
mon cher voilà au total gueule donc
première chose
secundo ce le bournot oui oui avait un
lien entre les deux mais ça ne fait pas
de là une tricherie et perso baute
refuse à verscio alafé 40 s'écoutait
bien a fait 45 millions de vues sur
l'émission wendy et populaire il y avait
un lien voilà les gens ont choisi à
risque de le revendre comme ami stop
une chose importante je trouve que pour
le coup cette personne était connu avant
les faits des spectacles et moi ça me
dérange qu'on vienne prendre trimer la
place de gens qui viennent à poursuivre
les shérifs ne pas faire agir tout le
monde maintenant six mois car la culture
à dire en france amérique au téléphone
eric antoine au téléphone j'ai eu eric
antoine de téléphone et il s'est jamais
caché de même avant ça parce qu'ils se
sont dit ça propose un problème il a dit
alors ah il a envoyé un mail en disant
je te préviens parce que la sollicite en
disant est ce que je peux participer à
quoi le talent dit si tu fais ce que tu
veux pour ta carrière ce qui est bien
par contre si tu fais ça on ne
travaillent plus ensemble jusqu'à ses
intérieurs et d'engrais à l'arrêt rendu
ici son bac es avec tout ça et il faut
bien se rappeler aussi que ces soprano
qui envoie le rôle à la tête
je pense qu'à tricherie il gardait
jean-michel pas avec eux à la démocratie
vraiment mal barré 1
on appelle les centrales d'appels pour
avoir des votes dans the voice
zazie sort avec un décor d'innocence m
gilles évidemment non l'aï les deux
magots mais comment ça c'est sûr
j'aimerais qu'il essaierait que ce
départ se désole appartement il ya un
lien de connivence
évidemment ça tu fais partie d'un jury
normalement il est humoriste et magicien
il connaît tous les magiciens clowns et
tous les eaux du golfe qui sont nuls à
l'aréa dernière c'est antonio qui a
gagné il connaissait très bien le
magicien aussi un art pose alors est ce
qu'une tricherie ou pas pour vous bien
sûr que ce n'est pas parce que je trouve
qu'il n'ya pas de vérité chérie au
passage au juste dans ce sens mais de
bons mais on s'essuie silence cette
enquête mais pourquoi laisser terminer
là dessus parce que dès le début dès le
début on voit que celui qui craque sur
aix et avant tout rozon qui est dupe et
à chaque fois